[Music]
we are taking our show down to San Diego
for comic-con we will be airing a week
of shows live from the Spreckels Theatre
in San Diego we got lots of exciting
stuff planned including interviews with
the cast of Silicon Valley cast and
creators of Game of Thrones and the cast
from the highly anticipated movie
Suicide Squad we have a ton of surprise
guest attorney stopping by and fun
moments planned it's all happening
Wednesday July 20th we start on a
Wednesday Wednesday July 20th through
Sunday July 24th for more information
visit team koco.com slash comic-con I
think it's gonna be a very good time now
to help us kind of get in the mood for
comic-con let's bring out Captain Kirk's
arch-nemesis trying his hand at stand-up
comedy for the very first time
please welcome Comic Con
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you yes yes great crowd
great to be here I know what you're
thinking Kahn has put on some weights
yes as the old Klingon proverb goes
revenge is a dish best served cold but
so is hazelnut gelato here's one
how many Captain Kirk's does it take to
screw in a light bulb
trick question that horndog will screw
anywhere but he's much too large to have
sex inside of an actual lightbulb Khan
don't call me a canoe do you even see
any paddles if I am a canoe then where
are my paddles I am NOT a canoe I am a
genius from hell's heart I stab at thee
for hates sake I Spit my last breath at
thee all right you know Khan that I
think that's quite wait at least let me
do my big closer
all right fine Khan do your closer thank
you yeah why did Captain Kirk cross the
road I I don't know Khan why because his
was stuck inside the chicken yes that
guy will screw anything
I think you can
[Applause]
this was not here before
[Laughter]
you